تفتح حولنا ليدا بيتها للاطلاع على وجه من
اوجه معاناه سكان ماريو بول التي انهكتها
الحرب
تعيش الاسره منذ اسابيع بلا ماء ولا تدفئه
ولا غاز ولا كهرباء
تقاومك غيرها من من بقي من سكان المدينه
املا في عوده الدفئ على اعتاب فصل الشتاء
شديد البروده
نريد استعاده الكهرباء
حتى نستطيع العيش بشكل طبيعي
درجه الحراره في الخارج ما يجبرنا على
ارتداء ملابس شتويه في البيت طفله صغيره
لا يمكنها ان تتحمل مثلنا نحن
هذه العائله التي احدثت قذيفه ثقبا في سقف
بيتها
وتتطلعه لاعاده اصلاحها قبل وصله بالخدمه
الاساسيه
يسابقه هؤلاء العمال الزمن لامداد حي سكني
بالتدفئه قبل نهايه الشهر
في اطار ورشه اصلاح كبرى تقول السلطات
انها تمثل اولويه لها قبل حلول فصل الشتاء
وهو تحدي يضاف الى تحديات اخرى تطرح امام
السلطات التي تسعى لاعاده بناء المدينه
بشكل كامل في غضون عامين
مبنا سكنيا والى جانب مد المنازل بمياه
التدفئه تشمل عمليه تغيير الوجه وابواب
الشقق المتضرره واغلاق الاسقف نسعى
للانتهاء من هذه العمليه قبل الثلاثين من
هذا الشهر تقول سلطات الروسيه اين مدينه
المريوط باتت مستعده بنسبه 70% لمواجهه
فصل الشتاء علما ان اكثر من 80% من
المنازل دمرتها المعارك التي ما زالت تدور
روحها في مناطق اخرى من البلاد
يحاول سكان ماروكو نسيانه
التي دمرتها المعارك على مدى اشهر توفير
الخدمات الضروريه لمواجهه فصل الشتاء بات
على الابواب مطلب اساسي تتوقف عليه حياته
نحوي 200 الف نسمه من سكان المدينه
امين درغام